so we'd film each other um so we could
use it on the show
she's filming me and i'm laying on the
table my water breaks she hits stop
record yeah she goes like puts the
camera
and goes what and during that whole
thing
literally has the camera off down and
like cannot believe that my water broke
like just so upset
y'all look so amazing
oh thank you so much now nick you make
sure that you are giving brie enough
room there with those sleeves girlfriend
i know i i knew if i wanted a tension on
me that's why i warm i'm like
we were taking a selfie earlier and i'm
like yo your shoulder pads my face
i love it but it's so beautiful you both
look great and i gotta say
huge congratulations to both of you
ladies on your little guys you've got
two little guys now
in the midst of things how are you doing
oh
we're doing good i mean a little sleep
deprived that's for sure a little
but a lot over here right we're so in
love
we're having so much fun and literally
our boys are like twins
they might not look alike but how they
are together it's so cute they
they're like we feel like little
brothers they do they're totally soul
brothers and like
i'm just i'm obsessed with being a mom
it's the greatest thing in the world
twins
pregnant together our bums kind of look
the same no they do not we feel the same
our cravings are the same wait first of
all my naked pregnant body is so hot
well it scared people it's so funny that
you mentioned that they're like brothers
because y'all told me back in june
you said i wouldn't be surprised if we
go into delivery at the same time
and sure enough you weren't far off
because y'all were a day apart
side by side in delivery rooms i mean
how crazy
and you know it was even because people
were like you had to plan it it's like
no her water broke
almost a week and a half early um i was
trying to go for a v back
and i was almost five days later you
were dying she was dilated for three
weeks
out of four yeah so i was going for a
vbac
so it didn't happen for me when we
walked into the doctor's office
and all sudden her water broke i
couldn't even smile at first i was like
listen to this i was like you'll get a
seat on total bellas
bruh but um
so she's filming because our cameras
weren't a lot in the doctor's office so
we'd always film so we'd film each other
um so we could use it on the show
she's filming me and i'm laying on the
table my water breaks she hits stop
recording yeah she goes like puts the
camera
and goes what and during that whole
thing
literally has the camera off down and
like cannot believe that my water broke
like just so upset i
love it i mean these two were just
destined to come into the world together
with each other
just like the two of you really but how
emotional has it been
for y'all to be together separated then
back together for your deliveries
i mean what a journey it really was
because i feel like with everything
that's been happening in 2020 with
pandemic it was like
we're really leaning on each other
because we were next door neighbors
and just doing everything together and
so
when i found out like she wasn't gonna
have her baby in phoenix i was just like
no you're supposed to like this year
you're supposed to like we need each
other
and she put me on emotional
rollercoaster like she always has
but um
you see it too this season of the
it's not that it was indecisive it was
like i had a plan but the pandemic
changed that and then it's like i think
what everyone was trying to figure out
in the world was like
you're trying to figure out how to go on
with your life but things were changing
daily
weekly like you just didn't know what to
expect right
so it was like affecting bree and i
where am i having my baby oh la oh wait
you know ellie does this make sense
phoenix
with phoenix it was like crazy i know
but you know something that i thought
was so relatable
especially just in this and of course it
happened in your season premiere
was the fact that nikki you guys you and
artem were looking at like okay
what is our job security looking like
and having to deal with the same sort of
you know consequence or you know
situation and it was just so
it was such a real moment for so many
people you know
bree and i love to be as like unfiltered
and just real and raw as possible like
even through this journey of trying to
lose pregnancy weight because you know
people have asked us like whoa you show
so much on your socials and i feel like
that's so important because i feel bad
for people who have the keeping up with
the joneses feel
like we shouldn't be that way like for
us
like we had to think about our family
job security
savings accounts and i was like i'm
never going to get into that hole so
like
if the way for my family to save money
was to have you know
insurance won't cover it they're
covering me in california we're going to
have it in california
and we'll adapt and you know it's in it
to me like because it is funny because
when you're on tv you'll even get like
networks
networks and stuff like i don't know
should we talk about that like
let me help people and i'm like no
that's real like we have to talk about
this
so you've been there before this is baby
number two for you but how have things
been
different or have they been different
this time around were they harder easier
for your second pregnancy
no gosh i have to say it was easier in
the sense
of i wasn't traveling as much during
pregnancy so
i just felt like my body and because i
had been pregnant before i just
understood it
but my boy through my belly button
so and he was another nine pounder
so this time around i actually had more
i hate saying damage done to my stomach
but i did i
i i'm on a very tough journey right now
and it's another c-section
so my abs are gone i have to rework on
those but
so many stretch marks you know it is
crazy
like i'm not gonna lie like when i see
myself naked i get
sad at times and i try not to and i try
to embrace like
like when i look at matteo go okay this
is worth it but it is
weird to see your body change so much
like my stomach like
i've always worked really hard on having
a tight stomach and like
i don't have any more like i had a
chiropractor here the other day and when
he did this
thing to pull out my leg i felt this
massive jiggle in my stomach and i go
what was that i go oh my god that was my
stomach like
it was the weirdest feeling but you know
what
you not to say that you're never ever
going to get your abs back ladies
because
you had that you were also doing like
300 plus sit-ups right before bed to
achieve those bad boys and now you've
got to be
nursing and feeding and changing but
like
you live that now you you know live this
and it's what a beautiful blessing you
know
i i agree and i told you how long do we
want to have the baby
so funny now okay since you had
mentioned this free that you had to
document your sister your sister
documented you
um with your appointments and things
like that because naturally the guys
couldn't go in because of covid right
now
but they were able to go in for delivery
and then they had to take the realms on
videoing the process so how did artem
how did brian do
did they video all of it did they manage
well
we're dead it was crazy because we went
in with like we had our little
baby luggage and then we went in with
like camera luggage
set up like three different camera
angles so we wouldn't miss anything and
you know i'm really excited i haven't
seen the footage yet my sister's giving
birth
because i wasn't allowed in there so i
can't wait to see her
push little mateo out and then i haven't
relived the footage
of when brian knight because we had a
surprise we didn't know we were having a
boy or a girl
why they literally when they pulled
buddy out they held him up and brian was
the first one
who got to see the goods to see if it
was a boy or a girl and he yelled out to
everyone like it's a boy
and so really neat because you know even
though we did everything on these like
cell phones
at the same time we caught some great
stuff have you seen the footage was
artem okay after i mean because usually
most
women and gents are like okay stay north
of the border
right i actually i haven't seen any of
it i am like
dying to see it oh i just am like
the one clip i see and i actually first
thought it was green and then i'm like
no wait that's me
when um at the end of the promo when i'm
like breathing really hard and i
remember that's when i was starting to
labor
um but because i'm so used to seeing you
have nerdy that i forgot
like what i like yeah i was like oh
they know that's me um so it was crazy
to see myself actually started to feel
like that pain again like oh my gosh
oh my god productions
like people are gonna be hearing me i
mean i am actually excited for people
to hear the part because
i had two more rounds of pushing until i
was gonna have to go into a c-section
and i literally told her i'm gonna put
on the lumineers like we're doing this
and i pushed him out i almost ripped
those bars off the hospital bed
our doctor said she's never seen before
someone's eyes just change like she goes
oh my gosh she's gonna do it just so
determined and boom
did it i gotta ask about artem so you
know
i he's been talking to us every week
with dancing of the stars we catch up
with him on a weekly basis
and we've been following his journey he
told us that he has lost
15 pounds since the season started and
that you nikki tell him that he needs to
eat more
so has a schedule of dancing with the
stars and now being a new dad
impacted him right well i mean i wish i
lost the 15 pounds
i have to lose it's like hey this can't
be opposite
like you're the guy here like i need to
feel skinny
it's never fair guys can lose weight
like at the drop of a hat so
knees and they have abs it's like
ridiculous
um yeah i mean it's definitely you know
of course
you know been difficult because dancing
with the stars they have such a
difficult schedule it takes up a lot of
time and i mean mateo's a little over
three months and so when you i mean it's
great i was telling you this last night
i go
can you believe we were in the hospital
not even 13 weeks ago pushing these
babies out
i'm gonna teach you the ropes artem all
right we already been swaddled before so
what's worse can happen
the baby's tired that's not a baby what
has it been like seeing artem as a dad
amazing he is an incredible dad he's so
it like since day one he's been very
natural
like a sweet soul i think with anyone
when you're in a relationship when you
all of a sudden see the man take that
father
role it's turned on yeah it's like
wow when you see them care for something
so much and unconditionally you're just
like damn
right so yeah so good so good now
how is your mama doing five percent
don't fully recover from bell's palsy
at the end of the day if it ended up
like this it's better than three weeks
ago
but the longer i go on the more i think
am i gonna have a full recovery
thank you for asking you know she's
doing good she has some really hard days
and she has really good days you know
having brain surgery
it's and you know half of her face is
still paralyzed so
it's slowly coming back but the recovery
is long and we keep reminding my mom
like
you're not going to get better tomorrow
like this is a six month two year
journey could be longer
and so she you know we've noticed like
she has really strong days and really
hard days but she's doing good
um on a lighter note on a lighter note i
did want to mention because i failed to
to mention this little tidbit
arden told us that mateo loves tv and
that you would kill him if you told
us
he said he's definitely grounded later
no i'm just kidding what you thinking
is is um i wear matteo plays a lot the
tv is right there
so i'll catch him like turning his neck
and i don't know maybe
it is me being a bad mom but i just
started
to like let him like why not like he'll
be in the swing and i let him look at it
because i'm like well it's not like
birdie when she's like hey
put on a show um i'm like he it's not
like he can tell me that and
i don't know if it's because when you
have a colicky baby you try to find just
ways
that make them happy and yeah good old
christmas shows actually even the news
because i watch the news so much
he just loves it he's destined for tv
both of them are testing for tv i hate
to break it to a
and b but it's you know they're destined
for it
and guys y'all revealed some big news
here recently you're both moving
to napa has it happened is it happening
where are you zooming from right now
please set the record straight
so we're zooming here from nicole's
house to los
angeles but i'm already a napa girl
she's already napa county i am i am
officially a napper girl
and i have to say i'm crazy and wild and
my poor husband
but it has been the best move and i know
arden nicole to come after the finale of
dance with the stars
i just i've always known we have a wine
we're always there and i'm always
would tell brian this is my happy place
and i think the one thing kobit has
taught me is like
why aren't you living where you're happy
like yeah i'm always like living in
places based on convenience or other
things
i'm like i need to go my happy place
like let's do this and i do it
i love it and your wine line has been so
successful so
would you see the show i imagine season
six is already a wrap
yeah you get the last episode is all
napa it's our move
you see how we have a really big online
purchase
and artem and brian i think we're crazy
but we're different and so the season
finale you see
why we moved to napa and how and we're
literally looking at
our houses for the very first time
that is the fountain of youth ladies so
do you hope for total bella season seven
to have the show based in napa focus
around your ventures there
your lives there yes if we do have
season seven we really want to showcase
napa valley and our close
friends there and why it's our happy
place and
like just building our wine lounge and
just
putting the bella stamp on napa okay
with tota bellas
yes i love it and i can see like an
iteration of total bellas being like
total bros
you know festering in the future with
buddy and matteo
and bertie well in total bros plus this
but i have a feeling we're going to see
more little uh bella's running around
here uh-oh
not from this end she took hers at her
tubes out yeah
i think what i heard free dead
why did you definitely make that
decision no i figured the stomach is
open they're right there
um i only want to like everyone saw last
season
that i really only wanted one and so you
know this pregnancy was an accident
but i'm so happy i mean now i can't
imagine life without buddy
and you do you know like you can't
actually have mistakes like
it happens so i was like it's there
let's just do it
and then my husband and i can have fun
the rest of our lives and not worry
that's a good way to look at it and i
got to tell you being a solo child like
you gotta have a partner in crime so i'm
so glad birdie has buddy now
nikki when are you getting when are you
adding to uh
your crew i think i'm one and done
no sis i don't see that happening
i told griego if you end up having a boy
i'm one in bed
like because we didn't know what she was
gonna have till she had it but i go
because he pretty much will have like a
breath there'll be twins
he'll have someone that he could always
relate to like all that but
yeah i just you know i don't know if it
was being pregnant having a baby in the
pandemic that scared me
or just gonna be 37 in a few weeks
um well no i just feel
i'm like my girls are like yeah we're
good